- [Voiceover] I can't go with
you here, just take a walk
around the block, or something.
- I can't keep going for a walk
every time you have to poo.
- [Voiceover] Just work with me!
- You poo three times a
day, then I'm so tired!
No, he's not gay.
I don't have to date him
just because he's not gay,
is attractive, and lives with me.
Am I on speakerphone?
Mom, you gotta stop doing.
Hello gram.
- Hey.
- Hey, what's up?
- Can I ask you something really quick?
- Yeah, what's up?
- You have to be completely
honest, all right?
- Okay.
- Why do women go to
the bathroom in pairs?
- Garrick, it's street
cleaning in five minutes
we have to move our cars.
- All right.
Could you, all right, cool.
- Are you coming?
- Yeah, just shut the
door and give me a second.
- Okay.
You promise you won't tell anyone?
It's to change each other's tampons.
- That makes sense.
- Is it because you're have a boner?
- Oh my God.
- Gross.
Hold on.
This happens every morning?
- Yes.
- Gross.
Hey guys.
- Hey, what's up?
- Nope.
No.
Hey, do you know why girls go
to the bathroom together?
- I never want things we were
just going to talk about stuff,
but literally we hardly talk.
It's a lot of, it's a lot of.
- It's a lot of pulling, right?
- A lot of physical.
Ha, sweet relief.
(burps)
(laughs)
(screaming)
- Kate, Kate, there's a spider.
Kate.
- Okay.
Where is it?
- Kate, Kate.
Get it, get it.
- Girl with the was baby.
(grunts)
Hello.
Oh no, it's not like that,
we're just roommates,
nothing sexual at all.
(laughs)
Gross.
You should see him eat spaghetti, ew.
(laughs)
- [Garrick] Chill.
How long is that string for real?
- It's standard, two and a half inches.
- What?
- Yeah, we have to tuck it up.
- [Garrick] Fold it.
- You have to tuck it up,
lap it over between the lips.
Good night?
- Yeah, you?
- Oh yeah.
We stayed up until 3 AM
watching "Harry Potter", so.
- That was a lot of commitment.
- I know.
I feel like he might be
emotionally unavailable though
and I have like a track record of dating
emotionally unavailable guys, and I don't
want to do that again, but we'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
- Pizza later?
- Yeah, is my middle
name Elizabeth? (laughs)
- Is it?
- [Kate] Yeah, it's Elizabeth,
What's yours?
- Uh, we're not there yet.
- What?
Why not?
Garrick?
- [Garrick] Yeah.
- Why do you have to fix the wall?
- [Garrick] Why didn't you fix the wall?
- Why would I fix it?
I didn't do this to.
- [Garrick] I don't know,
use your Harry Potter magic.
- I will only use my Harry
Potter magic for good,
and there's no reason you can't fix it.
- [Garrick] Magic isn't real Kate.
- [Kate] How dare you. (in deep voice)
(laughs)